دمرت روسيا حوالي 40 في المائة من
البنية التحتية للطاقة في أوكرانيا ،
بما في ذلك محطات الطاقة الحرارية التي
تزود العديد من المنازل والمدارس
الأوكرانية بالحرارة في فصل الشتاء
عندما تنخفض درجات الحرارة إلى 20 درجة
مئوية ،
ويبدو أن الرئيس بوتين قرر
أنه إذا لم يستطع الاستيلاء على أوكرانيا بالقوة
سيحاول تجميدها حتى الخضوع ،
فهذه مجرد أحدث جريمة
يرتكبها الرئيس بوتين
ضد شعب أوكرانيا
، فلم يكن كافياً ملء المقابر الجماعية في
البوتشا
والمدن ، ولم يكن كافياً قطع الطعام
والماء والدواء عن السكان.  في
استطلاع ماريو ، لم يكن كافيًا
اقتلاع عشرات الآلاف من الأوكرانيين بعنف
من منازلهم وترحيلهم إلى
روسيا من خلال ما يسمى بعمليات التصفية
على رأس كل هذا
الرئيس بوتين أيضًا
يخشى الأسلحة النووية
كما فعلت مجموعة السبع.  في كل خطوة نتعامل
مع التصعيد الروسي الأخير
معًا ونقف بحزم مع أوكرانيا عندما
الرئيس بوتين كلاي  ميد أن أوكرانيا كانت
تصنع ما يسمى بالقنبلة القذرة في ثلاثة
مواقع
طلبت أوكرانيا من هيئة الطاقة الذرية للتحقيق
بالأمس ، كشف خبراؤها زيف ادعاء بوتين
الكاذب
مع دول مجموعة السبع
حول العالم.
كارثية
بالنسبة له ولروسيا